i gave it back
all right good morning be seated ladies
and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen i do apologize for
the delay this morning we were ready to
go uh shortly after nine o'clock
i was on the bench and we were ready to
proceed but there was a a legal issue
that came up that involved not the next
witness but the following is one of the
expert witnesses so i wanted to resolve
that with counsel before we heard from
the witness so we didn't have to do it
either at sidebar or excuse you during
the doctor's testimony so i think we
have it resolved
and hopefully things will proceed
smoothly
we're going to hear from another lay
witness first council call your next
witness please
the defense calls boyd martin
uh please place your left hand on the
bible sir raise your right hand and
listen to my court clerk who will
administer an oath
do you swear in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony of this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do please state your name by
your last name for the record boyd
martin uh m-i-r-t-i-n thank you all
right mr martin have a seat please keep
your voice up nice and loud
if you don't understand a question
please indicate that to the court and
i'll have council rephrase go ahead
council good morning uh mr martin
um where do you live i live in
cochranville pennsylvania
are you a u.s citizen i am
uh
what do you do for a living
my wife and myself train uh horses my
wife's a dressage rider i'm a three-day
event rider uh in our sports three-day
eventing
uh has dressage show jumping and
cross-country it's an olympic sport
is um philip dutton uh also in that
sport yes he is okay
um
and do you compete nationally in the
united states yes uh and uh actually
internationally representing america
uh and in what competitions have you
represented america in international
competitions
um
i've gone to three olympic games i think
four
world equestrian games and i think two
pan-american games
um
do you know michael barrisson yes how
did you first come to know him
michael in the equestrian world is a
legend he's a very very well known uh
famous dressage trainer
i met him i believe in
2010
he's so good that
he started actually training and
coaching me
and helping me develop my riding in
dressage to a higher level
did he train you as well as your horse
yeah i mean he's a a remarkable guy he's
obviously a one of the best riders
in this country or if not the world
uh and i sort of went to him for
improvement of my own riding and the
improvement of horses he's uh
a brilliant horse trainer great mentor
coach competitor
also a guy that's been there and done it
that sort of helped help me in my career
and point me in the right direction
so approximately how many years of
experience do you have observing michael
barris on interactive forces
uh well since being in this country
probably uh watching him for a couple of
years before i started training with him
but uh closely sort of in a ten year
period
have you in that time period ever seen
michael barrasson abuse an animal
absolutely not uh michael uh
is a fantastic horseman uh to get the
the best out of the horses the thing i
learned with michael is
sort of trust and confidence and
you know he's a passionate trainer and
uh
you know really um
pointed me in the direction of sort of
working with the animal without force
did there come a time when your
relationship with michael evolved beyond
him being a coach and mentor into
something else
yeah i mean i i'm attracted to michael
just because of
his uh character and his personality and
i think over time uh you know you start
off as coach and student and um
and then uh you you somewhat develop a
friendship
um
you know i love the guy he uh
he was fun to be around uh he was
a great teacher
we had the same um
love for horses the same sort of goals
and drive for competition
and um
yeah i'd have to say that we became good
friends
did he assist you at all in uh
an appearance at the london olympics in
2012
yeah michael was was remarkable he uh he
actually flew to england and trained and
coached me at no cost
um
and he was instrumental on helping me
get to my first olympic games and
um
you know something i'll always remember
of how he sort of dropped everything
here in america and
came to england and and worked with me
um
to prepare for the olympics
were you at the rio olympics in 2016 yes
did michael assist you in connection
with that competition yeah he was um
coaching some of the pure dressage uh
riders of that contest um but he
definitely was an influence to me at
that point there i mean when you go to
the olympic games you
you know there's long build up there's
weeks of where you're sort of in a
training camp and uh yeah definitely
michael was there and um
an assistant
so did you develop a friendship with him
yes
uh did you ever socialize with them
outside of the context of horses
yes uh tell us about that
um like when you go to the
you know these championship events you
often you know training a horse takes
about an hour and uh you're there and uh
you hung out together you obviously had
dinner together um
my wife and myself owned a dressage
horse that we brought over from
australia
and
um we believed michael was so good at
improving horses we actually sent this
horse to his training facility in new
jersey and went up and watched michael
train the horse and
um enjoyed dinner with him afterwards
and
you know he was uh you see him at
competitions as well um
and uh he's a
i don't know like he's one of those
people you're drawn to at the show like
he's larger than life and uh
just fun to be around
based upon your
interactions with him professionally and
socially did you develop
any sort of impression as to
his
truthfulness as a person
yeah i mean he is a to me a very
honorable and truthful person i think to
achieve what he's achieved in his career
you can't be a con like it's so hard
work it's such a long road
it's just thousands and thousands of
hours of training and practice
and you can't
you can't get to where michael's got to
in his career
by being a phony and i'd say he's a very
honorable character he's truthful
and all the dealings i had with him as a
coach and student and him training our
horses and seeing him socially uh he was
a very truthful person have you ever
co-owned horses with michael
uh we had this one horse called jeff the
chef that michael trained and improved
and we ended up selling the horse
and so we owned the horse but
we
believe we michael got a commission on
the sale
do you have a barn facility in
pennsylvania
yes we have a farm in cochraneville
pennsylvania
was was there ever a time where there
was a a horrific fire at a facility you
were associated with
yeah unfortunately in 2011
i was actually renting a a
16 stall barn
um it was just
come to america in 2007 and
it was a tragic event it was
there was an electrical fire that
happened in the middle of the night from
an electrical uh product called a hay
steamer
and it was a disaster
this machine was a faulty machine
and the
machine caught on fire the whole
building burnt down
i believe six horses died the whole
building was destroyed uh we managed to
save a number of the horses but it was a
yeah it was a horrible horrible event
as a horse owner
if you had been in that barn and noticed
that that hay steamer was somehow
malfunctioning would you have done
something to address it
hold on hold on let me see it cyborg
sustained
you mentioned that michael was
passionate in his work
could you elaborate on that for the jury
i mean to be uh to be an olympic athlete
as successful as michael you've got to
have determination and drive and
positivity positivity uh you know he was
larger than life uh a passionate guy
i don't know how much more to explain it
but he he had a
flamboyant personality
he loved so much what he did um
it was really uh i was magnetized to it
a little bit like he when he's coaching
he could hear it in his voice or
you know there was times where he'd
wake up at three in the morning up here
in new jersey and drive to our farm and
be there before i even woke up to train
us and
you know he he just loved horses
he loved seeing us succeed
and he's he was just passionate about
his coaching and everything he did
throughout your association with michael
barisson did you ever witness him
mistreating another person
never no i mean there's
coaching any athlete i think
you know in sports there's times where
your voice would get elevated or you
might use a curse word but um
um you know i think it was definitely in
my experiences is just because of how
much he wanted you to improve but that
was never abusive or anything like that
no further questions
all right any cross-examination
thank you judge uh mr martin you weren't
at mr barriston's farm on august 7 2019
no and you're aware that he's on trial
for attempted murder yes no questions
josh thank you all right you may step
down sir thank you
[Music]
i call your next witness defense calls
dr steven simmering
dr simmer
hi doctor left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand as my clerk will
swear you in do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
i do please state your name and spell
your last name stephen with the v
simmering s-i-m-r-i-n-g
thank you
thank you doctor you may have seen thank
you please keep your voice up nice and
loud
go ahead direct examination
[Music]
good morning doctor morning
where do you uh reside currently
reside in tana fly in new jersey
and uh
what do you do for a living i'm a
psychiatrist
and um
can you give us
a little bit of background with regards
to your education yeah psychiatry is a
specialty of medicine
i went to college at columbia i went to
medical school at nyu i did my
general surgery residency at bellevue
hospital and then i did a psychiatric
residency at columbia presbyterian new
york state psychiatric institute
i after that i was in the u.s army
medical corps for three years what did
you do in the us army i treated
psychiatric patients who were military
usually vietnam
people coming back and forth from
vietnam
i returned then to new jersey i became
the medical director of mount carmel
guild community mental health center
which is part of catholic charities i
did that for about three years and then
i joined what was then called new jersey
medical school now known as rutgers and
for the next gee almost 30 years i was
director of medical student education at
new jersey medical school in newark
at times i was vice chair of the
department i ran the residency training
program but i was usually in charge of
medical student education
after that i returned to colombia where
i still am and i directed the forensic
or legal psychiatry training program at
columbia
throughout all this time i've been in
private practice of psychiatry where
i've seen
individual patients for therapy and i've
also done forensic or legal evaluations
and approximately
how many patients have you seen and
evaluated over your career i've seen
thousands of cases
and
how long have you been
in psychiatry well i i finished my
residency in psychiatry in
uh then i went to the army and then in
1973 i received board certification so
i'm a board-certified psychiatrist can
you explain to the ladies and gentlemen
the jury what's board-certified
well psychiatry is a specialty of
medicine like surgery or radiology in
order to do that you need to graduate
from medical school and finish and
approve residency
after that there's an examination to
measure your qualification
and i passed that examination in 1973
and became board certified oddly enough
uh it's lifetime certification nowadays
people have to do it every 10 years to
take recertification however i didn't
get away with it because in 2014
uh or no 1994 they developed a sub
specialty in forensic or legal
psychiatry and i passed that board and
that board is renewable every 10 years
so board certification means that after
completing all the requirements and
established board of experts will
evaluate your your uh capability and
competency
yeah do you have any uh or have you been
appointed according to any university in
the board
well yes i mean when i was at new jersey
medical school i sat on many many of the
committees uh i was there for many many
years and my work mainly involved
students
at columbia the same thing i was
involved with residents and the training
of residents as part of my columbia job
i also train
residents at cornell cornell has a
partnership with colombia through new
york presbyterian hospital so i spent
much of my life in academic medicine and
at the same time i've seen private
patients throughout this whole time
did you have any hospital appointments
yes i have a hospital well for many
years i was hospital appointed to
university hospital
in newark which is part of umdnj or new
jersey med school again now called
rutgers they keep changing the names
since 2005 when i returned to columbia i
received an appointment at columbia
presbyterian hospital known as new york
presbyterian columbia and then i
received an appointment at new york
presbyterian wild cornell that's the
east side hospital they have a
partnership in new york presbyterian
hospital so i have two hospital
appointments
have you received any uh awards or
honors with regards to your work in
psychiatry most of the awards i've
received over the years have been
teaching awards
how about any committee assignments
well that's part of academia as you
serve on committees everybody serves the
committee so you don't get much credit
for it but part of the duties in
academia is serving on committees
do you have any specific
research interests that you've
pursued medical student education
now
have you written any article
i've written a few not that many over
the years they're listed in my cd
yeah i've written a few books uh they're
more in in the field of populist
psychiatry more than uh academic
psychiatry for example i co-authored the
book
uh
making marriage work for dummies of all
things as part of the dummy series um i
wrote the compatibility quotient
co-authored that this has to do with
marriage i wrote a book with now the
current dean of uh new jersey medical
school robert johnson a book called the
race trap and this really has to do back
20 years ago about black white race
relations he's african-american so we
had it from the point of view of a black
and a white doctor we're going to revise
that book because race relations have so
totally changed in the united states
i've written a few other books
dr you ever been qualified as an expert
in a court of law i have many times
and when you say many times
approximately how many times probably
hundreds of times most of the time i've
been qualified in the state of new
jersey i should have mentioned i'm
licensed in new jersey and new york i
have an inactive license in california
so that in new jersey in new york i
practice mainly in new jersey
occasionally in new york and of course
my appointment at columbia and cornell
is in new york um
so uh
i'm sorry i forgot your question
i think you answered it let me ask
another one thank you have you ever uh
uh testified as an expert on behalf of
the state oh yeah the prosecutor thank
you i was telling you about testifying
most of my testimony has been in
superior court
in the state of new jersey i've
occasionally testified in supreme court
in new york which is the equivalent of
superior court
they have a
nutty kind of way of naming courts there
so their supreme court is like our
superior court i've testified in federal
court mainly in the state of new jersey
occasionally in new york that's called
the u.s district court
i've testified at arbitration hearings
as well i've testified occasionally out
of state um in psychiatry
and i've been qualified so i've been
retained
often by
i do civil and criminal cases in
criminal cases i've been retained by
defense lawyers like you by the
prosecutor i've worked for mr
shellhorn's office and i've worked for
many of the prosecutors offices in the
state of new jersey i've been retained
or appointed by judges to do specific
tasks
so i've been retained by people from
lawyers and judges from all sides
and you indicated that
you've been retained by the morris
county prosecutor's office in the past
oh i have yes
on one or more on on
you know comes and goes i i've testified
in most of the counties in the state
i've been retained by many of the
prosecutors offices public defenders
offices and private attorneys
in morris county i did a lot of cases
when michael murphy was the county
prosecutor at that time
here in mars
here in mars uh and uh judge
michael murphy was the prosecutor at
that time after him i started doing
fewer cases here more cases in bergen
and essex but over the years i've done
mars county cases
now
judge at this point i'll move dr
simmering as an expert in psychiatry
forensic psychiatry right
right yes all right any objection or do
you have any questions for the doctor
solely related to his qualifications as
an expert no judge thank you all right
very good uh dr simmering
will be qualified by the court as an
expert pursuant to rule 702
based on his uh training his knowledge
his education skill and experience he
has been qualified before and he'll be
qualified this time as an expert in the
area of forensic psychiatry and he'll be
allowed to render his opinion
thank you
welcome doctor go ahead mr balance can
you explain to the jury what forensic
psychiatry is
well forensic psychiatry is a
sub-specialty of psychiatry just as
psychiatry is a sub-specialty of
medicine it's a discipline and i i have
been qualified as an expert in
psychiatry with a sub-specialty in
forensic psychiatry forensic scientist
is the application of the specialty of
psychiatrists specifically to legal
issues
and legal issues come in a lot of
varieties many of them are civil cases
where one person is suing another and
brings up a
a psychiatric issue a simple example of
that may be a will contest where the
state of mind of the test state or the
will maker is brought into into a
question
some of these cases have to do with
claims of damages medical malpractice or
sexual harassment or things like that
then there are criminal cases such as
this one and in a criminal case uh i
will render opinions as to an
individual's state of mind an
individual's dangerousness from a
psychiatric point of view
an individual's competency or fitness to
stand trial
um a uh
another
factor is dealing with an individual
state of mind as it applies to the
criminal charges and as i've testified
i've been retained by defense
prosecution and the court to render
these opinions
what's the
difference between a psychiatrist and a
psychologist
the training is very different for the
purpose of testifying psychologists can
do very much what i do in telling the
jury
giving the jury expert opinions about
a person's state of mind however the
training is very very different
psychiatry is a specialty of medicine
you can't go into psychiatry unless you
go to medical school you know the old
joke was a psychiatrist is a doctor who
doesn't like to see blood and you know
that's a little bit funny but it is a
specialty as
surgery internal medicine gynecology any
other specialty
psychology is an academic study
and instead of getting an md degree in
specializing as you do in psychiatry you
will aim toward a phd degree or a
psyd degree and you get an academic
degree and then you take courses and
then you become a specialist in
psychiatric issues so there although the
training is very different they often
converge in two places one place is the
psychiatrist and psychologists
both often provide therapy so both can
be qualified to be psychiatric
therapists
second thing is both psychiatrists and
psychologists can do evaluations
i think the one place in which
psychiatry has an advantage in doing
evaluations is questions of medication
where medication is concerned because
part of my training is training in the
use and prescription of medications the
one place where psychology has an
advantage is in testing pen and paper
psychological testing where they have an
advantage
doctor were you uh retained to evaluate
michael barrisson's
state of mind at the time of this
incident i was i was asked to see mr
barrison uh shortly uh after really
within a month of the incident which
occurred in early august 2019. now is
there any significance as to
[Music]
when you see a particular individual
as far as the closeness to the event
with regards to rendering an opinion
well ideally you want to do an
evaluation as close to the event as
possible because it's fresh and
everything is fresh
the ideal circumstance is getting a call
from an attorney to see his client in
jail
or really in some kind of custody
or in the office
it would be great to see somebody
shortly afterwards that often doesn't
happen
very often because of the way the court
system works i'm asked to see somebody
months or even years after an event and
then i have to reconstruct what had
happened that's certainly possible but
it makes it more difficult here in this
case i was asked to see mr barrison the
first time on september 6 2019 which is
just a tiny bit more than a month after
the incident
okay and uh
again
on that day you met with michael
barrasson correct i did
uh and that was in person yes it was
that was just before the past well it
was just before the pandemic yes
and
after the pandemic did you have an
occasion to meet with him on other
occasions i met with mr barrisson four
more times
throughout the year 2020
all of which were done by zuma
by that time much of my evaluations were
being done by zoom like most other
mental health professionals right did
you
interview anyone else other than michael
barrasson to
formulate your uh opinion in this matter
yes i had phone telephone interviews i
first i read all the records
statements paid by many many people
including
michael barrasso's girlfriend mary
haskins clark
i've read statements by the victim in
this case her boyfriend people involved
in her life
i
spoke by phone specifically the two
people one is stephen tarshis who is mr
barrissone's long-term lawyer and he was
involved in trying unsuccessfully to put
a stop to what was going on between mr
barrissone and um
uh anders kanarek if i can stop you for
a second doc uh why did you contact
stephen tarshish at michael
there's a complicated case as i'm sure
the jury knows but one of the issues was
that as time went by
mr barrissone was trying everything
within his power to stop the
relationship between him and cataract
and goodwin in other words he wanted
them off his property and he wanted them
to leave they didn't want to leave
that's the simple part of it so he
wanted them to leave they were squatting
they didn't want to leave they claimed
they had a right to be there so mr
barrison tried everything in his power
to get them to leave and among other
things he contacted the washington
township police on at least four
occasions and probably more than that
and ask for the help hold on a second
can i see council at sidebar please
testimony was not exactly responsive so
please ask another question
and i'm not sure we have to get into why
he spoke to someone because that
probably led the doctor to
testify as he did so
he certainly indicated who he spoke to
that's fine but
why he did it
information he received from those
people is not
something he should testify to now
of a sudden in criminal cases reduced a
jury to seven jurors
i didn't think so i should have made
that clear at the outset thank you so we
have 16
including the first two rows thank you
didn't want to ignore the rest thank you
doctor i see that you're referring to
your report uh i'm just going to
give you a comment hold on mr blinkist
there's an issue with the court smart
recorder
all right we're good go ahead mr
malinkas
just so the record is clear i've marked
a copy of your report d 900
e-1 which i'll i'll place here
so if if you're referring to your report
which is not a problem um just indicate
so and
that's the exhibit network that has been
marked thank you i have my own copy of
mr blankes now
you indicated you spoke to uh the
attorney
did you speak to anyone else
with regards to michael barrison that
you used
and relied on as far as your evaluation
yes i spoke to his uh long-term
uh
therapist
who has seen him in therapy for years
and um
her
it's miss ricardo i'm looking at her
first name i'm blocking on that
i'm going to refer you to the first page
of your report second paragraph sp to
review oh here we go yeah thank you
uh and picardo sorry i spoke to ann
picardo uh mr barristone had been seeing
ann picardo for therapy off and on for
many years so with mr barrisson's
permission i spoke to miss piccardo to
gather her thoughts about his background
and did you receive information from
ricardo
that
you relied on with regards to the
formulation of your opinion i did and
can you tell the jury what information
she provided you
that you relied on as far as your
evaluation here
well i'm not sure how much detail you
want me to go into
whatever detail
that you relied on and you believe it's
necessary to explain why you rendered
the opinion that you did okay
um
uh
i can refer you to page 15.
thank you
sorry those are the past personal
history
um
what i learned from her
is that uh he came from a
family which was emotionally and
physically abusive
that as a boy growing up
his mother according to her was very
selfish and very abusive to him his
mother by the way passed away in 2014
his father died in 2019 just after his
his arrest uh miss picardo remembered
that in terms of the history that uh one
of the maternal grandparents suffered
from depression and she believed that
one of the grandparents required shock
treatment electroconvulsive therapy and
why is that relevant
well depression runs in families and one
of my diagnoses uh
of my two diagnoses one of them is
persistent depressive disorder or
chronic depression
and so that was relevant with regards to
your diagnosis regarding
the depressive
diagnosis that's correct
just one more piece of evidence people
with depression often have depressions
in the family some do not many do all
right and what else if anything you rely
on she told me it is even more important
miss piccardo said that she had treated
mr barisson on and off for 20 years
never consistently but on and off for
depression and anxiety
and he would make appointments with her
and see her when he felt he needed care
she described him to me as this is a
direct quote very troubled
she thought he was at a considerable
risk for suicide and she believed that
even before the current events
he expressed to her after he spoke to
her after
the incident that he had lost everything
she also noted that throughout the years
in addition to being depressed he
appeared to be paranoid by which she
meant unduly suspicious of the motives
of others
and how is that
information relevant to your diagnosis
well my diagnosis is based on my review
of the records which are extensive my
review of the medical records the
incident reports
my five interviews with mr barristone
and also other information that comes
through such as medical records and
impressions from other treating
professionals all that helps me to
formulate a diagnosis
uh can you set forth uh uh generally
what you reviewed uh that you relied on
that forms your
uh
opinion yes material is extensive as the
jury can see from this pile of papers on
my desk that's more than eight inches
thick
but uh just to summarize it i i had and
i'm reading now for my report where i
summarized everything
the legal documents uh washington
township investigation reports
which had to do with the current
incident
and um
visits that washington township made to
mr barrissone before the incident
dealing with difficulties he was having
with ms canorack and miss goodwin
doctor did you review uh um the reports
with regards to michael barrasson's 911
i did there were several there were at
least four 911
short in the days before the shooting
incident in which mr barrissone was
increasingly uh panicky and increasingly
desperate to get help for a situation
which had been spinning out of control
and he put these in the form of 9-1-1
calls
officers responded to the scene
but didn't do very much
and what
if any impact
did that have on michael barrett's own
state of mind
during this mr blencus can i see you for
a minute
doctor with regards to the numerous
times that michael barrasson contacted
the washington police department and
called 911.
did you discuss with him
his
feelings and beliefs with regards to
those interactions with the police yes
not i did not discuss it with the police
i discussed the reports with mr
barrisson and what did michael barrasson
tell you
uh with regards to these numerous
attempts to try to uh get the town to
assist him mr barrison said he was
scared to death of lauren kanarak and he
wanted help in any way he could get it
that he had tried everything he knew
calling his lawyer calling the police
trying to speak directly to lauren
kanarak and her father jonathan
speaking to goodwin speaking through
intermediaries on the farm but nothing
worked and in the last several days
prior to the shooting itself he implored
the police for their help in putting an
end to the situation
okay focusing
specifically just on his
contact with the police
what impact did that have on his mental
state if anything well mr barrison
became increasingly desperate because he
saw himself in a situation in which he
was being physically threatened
by lauren canorack and robert goodwin he
felt trapped he felt that there was no
way out despite the fact that he owned
the farm that he had a reputation that
he had funds that he had education he
felt that he was
unable to do anything to make this
situation go away and to get lauren
cataract to
leave now
in your interviews with michael barrison
did you have any
difficulty
communicating with him
uh at any point well yes the difficulty
i had communicating with him is he went
into incredible detail about everything
and it was very hard to pin him down to
try to get a trend of what he was
thinking he would answer the question
and then he would go off on showing me
posts that lauren cataract did on
facebook with all kinds of fantastic
threats
stories about
chess games
stories about other people and it was
hard to focus him on what his actual
thinking was because he was so
preoccupied with cataract and remained
preoccupied even after the shooting and
even after his arrest
and he was was he that same way in each
and every meeting that you had
he was now he was worst when i first saw
him i first saw him in uh within a month
a little more than a month after the
shooting i then saw him four times in
fairly
uh close uh uh proximity in april of
2020. so by that time a year uh two
years have passed or and i'm sorry a
year had passed
and um
uh he had improved a little bit but he
remained focused and he remained
uh
he wouldn't stop talking about what
happened and what lauren cataract was
doing and what she was still doing he
wouldn't stop writing he was continuing
to demonstrate to
produce
documents saying all the things that she
did to him and all the things he was
afraid that she would do to him
it reached the point where i said to him
that i cannot process all this
information
would you please restrict it to a
hundred pages
i rarely have to do that with somebody
usually with examinees and with patients
i want them to produce everything they
can but with him i said i cannot read
thousands of pages i want you to boil
this down and he finally did produce 4
million 91 page document with the high
points now
i show you what has been marked defense
exhibit 900
e-3
is this a copy of that
document you wish michael barrasson to
produce right this is the 91-page
document uh it wasn't numbered so uh at
when i reviewed this review mr blinkis
we numbered the pages for easy reference
i have my own copy
okay now um
did you review and rely on what's
contained
in that document in formulating your
opinion yes uh among other things i i
don't think i ever finished my last
question about the materials that i
reviewed
and and i i started by saying i reviewed
the washington township police reports
both during the investigation of the
shooting itself and the four uh visits
the washington township police made to
mr barrisson prior to the shootings
where he was imploring their help in
solving the situation i reviewed
investigation reports by the morris
county prosecutor's office
i reviewed reports by local police
i reviewed the indictment criminal
complaint the search warrant
i reviewed documents that had to do with
um um
uh
trying to obtain uh
uh
mr barristone was convinced that bugs
had been placed listening devices had
been placed throughout the farm so he
retained a private firm called bug
sweeps to try to figure out where these
bugs were and what they were recording
i obtained
medical records and this had to do with
the emergency room visit the emergency
squad that came out to the farm after
the shooting
and they took miss cataract to the
hospital they also took
uh mr uh uh barristone who had been
injured himself in the in the episode
i read the notes from the emergency
responders who were first on the scene
to gather their impression of what
things were happening i read the doctor
reports from mr cataract and mr
barrissone
um
then finally i read an extensive file of
correspondence text messages and social
media posts largely from lauren cataract
but others as well and the bulk of this
lengthy pile of documents that you have
here have to do with these posts
and text messages
was it brought to your attention that
there were over 19 000
pages of
social media posts from lauren cataract
oh well yes that's why i told mr
barristone there is no way
you're gonna get me to read nineteen
thousand pages i have better things to
do if you want me to do this you're
going to have to boil this down to 100
pages and then i'll read it that's
pretty unusual because normally in cases
i kind of scrounge for every scrap of
relevant material i could get but there
was so much of this stuff
now
was michael barristone
ever able in any of your meetings with
him
was he ever able
to
discuss the
specific incident with you
well he talked about what happened up
until the time he jumped into his truck
and drove down to
the place where
lauren cataract and robert goodwin were
residing he remembered nothing about the
incident itself and then he talked about
the aftermath
so as far as the actual incident
he was never able to give you any
specific details
each and every time you talk to him that
is correct he gave me no details and he
gave law enforcement no details
now
you did realize that he is charged with
a criminal offense correct absolutely
and
did his
and i'm going to describe it as amnesia
with regards to that portion of the
event
cause you any concerns
and if so what did you do to address
those concerns well not at all he got
hit on the head which is probably the
most likely reason that he lost memory
uh during the confrontation
it happened very quickly and what
happened is not very clear but one of
the things
seemed to be that robert goodwin hit him
on the head with his cell phone and he
suffered a hematoma behind his ear and
some other head injuries that's the most
likely reason that he lost his memory
however your question has more to do
with his current fitness to stand trial
does he remember enough to stand trial
and my answer to that is absolutely
because he can provide the entire
background he can provide details of all
the interactions between him counteract
goodwin
and all the other relevant principles
and he can account for what happened
afterwards the fact that he got hit on
the head and don't remember the shooting
itself
does not undermine his ability to stand
trial
and does not undermine my ability to
make a determination about what his
mental state was because there was
abundant evidence of his mental state
leading up to the actual shooting
now
with regards to his inability to recall
the specific events
uh you've indicated that um the blows to
his head
uh may very well be the
uh
the cause of that
probably i mean there's another
possibility when people are in periods
of high anxiety as he was he was uh
terrified when he jumped into the car as
far as i could tell he grabbed a pistol
he owned guns but he grabbed a pistol
it's kind of a ladies pistol a pink
pistol referred to as the ladies pistol
that belonged to his friend dr ruth cox
and he did it very impulsively jumped
into his car drove down there and
according to him he was afraid he'd be
killed and wanted to defend himself
now when people are in states of high
anxiety like that like any anybody can
remember like being say in a car
accident or being the victim of a crime
sometimes memory is not completely clear
for everything that happens because
anxiety is so high however i think the
most simple explanation is he got hit on
the head okay now
can you say definitively to a degree of
medical certainty
what the specific cause was either the
head injury or the
mental
state caused by anxiety well counselor
as you all know i can't say anything
definitively
i can offer an opinion to a reasonable
degree of medical probability which
means that it's highly likely medically
i can't testify as to anything at the
certainty also there are data missing
here about exactly what happened and and
i've read all the witness statements to
try to put it all together i think the
most likely explanation for his amnesia
is she got hit on the head and it's well
known and well documented that he got
hit on the head i read reports from
morristown memorial documenting all of
his injuries i think there is also the
possibility that his enormous
overwhelming state of anxiety may have
affected his memory that's the best i
can tell you okay now uh did you review
any documents
with regards to michael barrissone's
state of mind immediately after the
incident
that
you relied on in helping you form that
opinion that you just testified well yes
there were many observers mainly the
trained observers from the emergency
squad emergency medical services and
everybody described the same thing he
was oriented to
person and and place in other words he
knew he was michael barrisson
and he knew that he was on his farm so
he knew that however every observer
commented that he was confused about
what had just happened
every observer who saw him there must
have been a dozen observers on the scene
in the hospital emergency room in the
emergency bay at the hospital everybody
commented that he was confused about
what actually happened and actually to
this day
not to this day but to the last time i
saw him in april of 2020 he still did
not remember exactly what happened he
remembered what led to it he remembered
having the visitors from child
protective services he remember jumping
into his truck he remembered being
threatened and he remembered uh being
treated for injuries but did not
remember what happened in between
now that's different from knowing who he
is or where he is he did know who he is
and where he was
now
did you have discussions with michael
barrasson with regards to uh
various social media posts
i had extensive discussions with him
about media posts and the media posts
were almost all done by lauren canorack
some of them were old media posts where
she had posted
comments
about
other individuals often very negative
comments about other individuals i
discuss that with him if i can stop you
there john i'm going to show you what
has been marked
d 900 e-4
which is a
social media post from uh a woman named
staggered
and captured
this is what we talked about this
morning not getting into the details why
are you showing it to him
you're not getting into the details
which the court excluded why even show
it to him
doesn't that run the risk of an improper
comment
no because i i thought you told me i
could leave here
not as to the details that was part of
my ruling
details judge
all right go ahead just be careful
doctor
i'm showing you 900 e
4 and 5
for the record their posts
from cataract to staggered
and from cataract to parkinson
do not say what's contained in here i've
seen these posts and did you discuss
these posts with michael barrasso i did
and
without
just discussing the content
how would you describe these posts
objection
you're asking this doctor's opinion on
it how did michael barrasson describe
exactly these posts to you without
referring to the content he found them
very scary
what effect did
those posts
based on your discussions with michael
barristan
have
on his mental state
these were just more uh
more pieces of more bricks more more
pieces uh of a building um fear that he
had of lauren canorack he became
increasingly terrified of miss canorack
and increasingly terrified of what he
believed lauren cataract
could do to him and to his girlfriend
mary haskins gray
and over the time certainly over the
last month to prior to the incident he
became increasingly terrified of what he
regarded as lauren's power to destroy
him to destroy mary haskins gray
to destroy his
farm to destroy mary haskins grace
family uh and these posts were simply
more links in to build up this this
terror
i can't point to any one post and say
this is what did it but there was an
ongoing series of posts which he found
increasingly terrifying
and is it your
opinion that each and every
post
to a certain degree
played a role in his
decline of his mental state absolutely
was a build up he became increasingly
terrified and increasingly paranoid
did you discuss with michael barrasson
lauren canarax post about going to war
yes
[Music]
i'm going to show you exhibit 200 a 85
200 a 25
and 200 a
84.
can you review these and tell me if
these are some of the posts that you
discussed with michael byrson with
regards to cataracts
posting about going to war
yes these the most relevant thing about
these posts are they all occurred in
late
um
july 2019 which is within a couple of
weeks of the incident
and what effect did
those posts have on michael barrasso
there's no single post that i could say
did any single thing it was a buildup
and continued to play on his fears he
became increasingly panicky if you take
any one post out of context you may say
gee maybe this is a joke or gee maybe
this is a game
but at this point he had begun to take
these posts extremely seriously and
literally and believe that she had power
to do all of these things that she was
threatening to do in the posts so with
each one it turned up the ratchet of the
pressure and mr barrissone became
increasingly distraught increasingly
frightened
sure
i have all these you can have those as
well
not
available
[Music]
i'm trying not to get well
can we be heard at sidebar sure
rephrase your question please in this
regard doctor i'm going to show you
exhibit 200 a 36
200
a 53
200
a 63 and 200 a 62
with regards to
thank you weapons and guns
yes
can you just look at all of them quickly
i'm familiar with that i've read all
this
right
and what impact did those posts have on
michael barrasson's mental state well
it's the same thing uh first of all
you have to look at the dates of these
posts uh some of them are much earlier
in april of 2018.
so
some of this goes back
much before the actual incident so in
the first set of posts and i won't go
into reading any of these things they're
all threatening they all have to do with
guns they have to do with uh
with weapons with robbery uh with uh uh
you know you can take all of it
literally uh but all of it has a
threatening aspect to it so the first
set of posts the important thing is this
was april of 2018. this is more than a
year before the incident
the second set of
can i see posters
but mr blink proceed in accordance with
the court's decision at the bench please
doctor
did you discuss with michael barrissone
posts from lauren canorack
where she talks about
mental health issues on her behalf yes
did you discuss with him specific posts
that he saw prior to the shooting with
regards to
lauren cataract and her
mental health issues yes counselors i've
discussed many of them after a while i
had to stop the discussion because he
would have kept me there all day showing
me posts and it just reaches a point
where it's no point yes to your answer
he did discuss specific posts about her
mental health and alleged mental health
issues which i think this is one of the
topics i had asked if there could be a
limited instruction about
yes
i i was going to give some limiting
instructions at the end of the testimony
before your cross-examination
would you rather me give it now uh no
judge if you're inclined to give it at
the end because there's a number of
different topics i don't want to keep
interrupting any more than i already
have understood um what's necessary i'll
give the limiting instructions at the
end of the direct
about any topics covered that deserve a
limiting instruction and i'll include it
in my final charge as
doctor i'm going well show you defense
exhibit 208 77 and 208-1
and ask you
if you review these
with michael barrasso
yes i did
yeah the first thing i look at
especially with all these records is the
date is the most important thing and
you've given me a handful of messages
some of which were april of 2019
which would have been four months or so
before the incident and the others were
a few days before the incident in august
of 2019.
and did michael barrasson indicated that
he was
researching warren cataract at any time
yes
and did he indicate that he was to the
middle objectives or leading questions
well
i'll allow it in this area just to get
to the point
did he indicate that he was pulling up
all her facebook posts from
uh
previous periods of time he was
and and
with regards to
those ones you have before you
how did michael barristone
how did those posts affect michael
barrett's own state of mind he became
increasingly panicky he became obsessed
with her posts preoccupied with her
writing and the more he dug into it the
more panicky he became
at some point in time
did you discuss with michael barrasson
his belief that he was being recorded
yes
and and
what discussions did you have with
michael barriston concerning that and
what effect did it have on his mental
state well he was being recorded in fact
he hired as i testified to the jury
earlier
what called a bug sweeping service
i saw documentation of individual
professionals who go around trying to
find listening devices and they did
indeed find some listening devices and
in fact uh i believe that lauren
cataract acknowledged placing listening
devices and some of the comments that he
made in private in his own residence
somehow got back to him in terms of a
facebook post or something like that and
he became increasingly
anxious and panicky when he saw some of
the things he was talking about in the
quiet of his home was being put on
facebook probably through
listening devices
that increased his panic and sense of
desperation
did
did he know a hundred percent for sure
based on your conversations with him
that he was being recorded initially
council nobody knows anything 100 for
sure
including your client and and what
effect from a mental standpoint did
his belief that he would be recording
half on
if any on his mental decline it poured
fuel on the fire he he had uh as more
and more posts were taking place and
more and more of these events
more and more things getting back to him
the bugging
everything else like that
he was being i guess in a colloquial
word gaslighted that his reality was
being toyed with and he became
increasingly panicky
and and the more panicky he got the less
rational he got in dealing with things
and this in the context is a man who
despite his
background of depression is a man who
has always been a very rational person
he was no longer rational
now you use the term gaslighting can you
explain to the jury what that means
well it's not
it's not a a proper psychiatric term of
the dsm but it's one commonly used and
and it's a term that that it started
really from an old movie uh of a man
trying to
play with his girlfriend or his wife's
reality by turning on and off a gaslight
i forgot the details but the idea is
where somebody it often happens in the
context of a romantic relationship but
it can be other relationships like this
one where one individual tries to play
with another's individual's reality by
inserting facts changing facts doing
things changing things and where the
individual bites bites as it were and
accepts this that's called gaslighting
where they start questioning their own
sense of reality where they no longer
know they're they're like adrift at sea
they no longer know what the guideposts
are about reality and that was what's
been happening to him and therefore
looking at more 19 000 posts my god i
mean all he did all day and all night is
read these posts and and instead of
reassuring it him
it made him even more panicky
did you discuss with michael barrasson
uh lauren cataract posting
things saying that her life was
in danger or threatened by michael
barrasso yes
and
did you discuss that with michael
barrasso i discussed all of it with him
up to the point that i couldn't take it
anymore and i said enough
the session is finished i don't want any
more and then i would see him again i
stopped after four sessions because it
was no longer productive i would just
hear the same stuff and more posts and
more posts and what you're seeing here
on my desk is only a small sample of the
posts there is this kind of oddly enough
there was a little psychiatric concept
called hypographia where some people
when they're anxious right all the time
for everything
in today's world it's more like
hyperpostia that that uh lauren
counteract
i mean she's not the only one in the
world that does this for sure but
everything got posted
there were countless numbers of posts
i'm going to show you d702
did you let me give these back to you
did you review that document
yeah this is a document from usa bug
sweeps
i guess there is such a profession
called bug sweeping and what they
there's a contract that mr barris owned
paid five thousand dollars
to this bug sweeping company
to
check out his rather large property of
farm and stables to try to find bugs or
listening devices and they followed
through on that contract
now
what effect did
he got increasingly paranoid the more he
did
to try to assure himself the worse
things got because the more he
investigated the more he found and the
more panicky he got and nobody seemed to
be able to stop it
but i'm saying nobody i'm talking about
his loved ones nobody seemed to be able
to stop it everybody noticed that he was
no longer the same person that he had
become depressed preoccupied strange odd
but
in his own mind he thought the solution
to this was investigating further and
further and further but the more he
looked the worse things got
it was like like a house of mirrors
did you discuss with michael barrasson
him hiring a
private investigator to do a background
check of cataract and goodwin he did
yeah one more one more futile effort
to try to reassure himself he hired a
private investigator
who did
some kind of background check of
cataract and goodwin when i say some
kind
i never saw a formal report
excuse me but mainly they they found
some records in north carolina okay
i'm going to lead you through this next
series of questions i'm going to show
you d he said he said he never saw the
report
he sold this judge he just said he never
saw the report
doctor did you see a background check
that michael barrasson got
with regards to cataract
counselor i said i never saw a formal
report
what i saw are random records of arrests
in north carolina and some comments from
the investigator but i never saw a
formal report in the sense of a formal
investigation
i'm going to show you 700 a1
is this the
informal report that you
reviewed
he never said he saw an informal report
is this the report he never said he saw
a report he said he saw random records
and comments by the investigator these
are the records he's referring to i
believe well let him answer that
answers
excuse me correct
these are records
that um
have to do with traffic records
okay i'm sorry you can't discuss the
content
are these the records
that you reviewed with regards to what
was provided to michael barroso uh these
and a few others yes
now
these records
indicate that there were numerous
arrests for both individuals correct
just yes or no i i don't know how to
categorize universe
more than one
more than one yes your honor
and
did you discuss
those records
and michael barrasson's uh beliefs
with regards to his review of those
records
yes and his mounting panic and these
records were more embers in the fire
did you discuss with michael barrasson
him hiring a person to
sit
outside of the stable area at night
and guard the stable area he did i
believe that was larry davidson and
is that also something that fueled
well yes everything he tried to do which
on the surface
would provide some level of protection
against his perception of danger only
increased the danger and made it even
worse
did you discuss
doctor with regards to your testimony
concerning
increased danger
was that michael barrasson's impression
of what was going on yes
now
i'm going to show you
the four posts
defense exhibit 208 83
a81
986 and
9.
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
these um
are these four postings from lauren
cataract
postings that you
specifically talked to michael baristone
about
again i'm looking at dates
yes these are loosely called manifesto
one two three and four i suppose
who gave them that terminology
uh
lauren canaric
now
with regards to these posts and your
discussions with michael barrison
can you
tell the jury how
these specific posts
affected
his mental state he believed all this
stuff uh as she was as miss cataract was
gaslighting him he believed it and uh
although many of the things of these
posts i
find fantastic he believed it and he
believed it literally and he believed
that all of these things presented a
danger to him and to his family
and with each post it turned up the
screws and made him more anxious and
more panicky
did you discuss
with michael barristone why he left his
residence
and started living in the stables
yes it was sort of a complex story but
apparently a report had been made
to the town inspection facilities
reporting on unsafe conditions within
the dwelling and there were two
dwellings on there and at that time he
was sharing one of the dwellings with
cataract and goodwin but there was a a
report made and it had to do with um uh
unsafe conditions i never could get that
exactly straight there had been a burst
pipe at one point
there was some question about how many
people were living in the dwelling and
if there was a
adequate septic tank coverage for that
but whatever it was the bottom line was
and mr
uh goodwood mr um uh
barristone believed that he had been
reported to the town by cataract and
goodwin not sure who reported the town
but he believed cataract and goodwin did
that in any event the town came and they
enclosed the facility said it was
uninhabitable until remediated and he
had to leave
as did cataract and goodwin and they had
to fortunately was middle of the summer
and they had to sleep outdoors while he
remediated these problems
okay and can you describe what if any
impact
barristone having to
live outside
had on his mental state most playing
with his mind even more he no longer
could be in familiar surroundings he was
outdoors things are becoming
increasingly strange and disorienting
for him
on the day of the uh
incident
um
did you review any documents with
regards to dcpp
coming to the farm area i did it's dcp
and p it's what nyfus is called nowadays
in new jersey basically child protective
uh apparently a report had been filed
with child protective
that children these were children of um
mary haskins uh gray mr barristol not
his children but her children who had
visited the farm from time to time and
these documents made a report an
anonymous report because these reports
are always anonymous that these children
were in some kind of danger
and that was my understanding that two
one or two representatives of d
dcp and p
division of child protective and
permanency came down to visit and wanted
to question mr barrisson about these
allegations of abuse of these children
now
did you discuss that with michael
barrasso i did what what did he
specifically tell you with regards to
that contact with dcpp was the final
straw
what effect do you believe
that had
a much of
a state of mind it was the final straw
now
when you do an evaluation doc can you
explain to the jury
how you come
to what your opinion is
well evaluation is a formal exercise
what you do is
it starts with the review of records and
depending on the evaluation the records
could be really very brief maybe one
report
or they could be very lengthy like in
this case so you spend i spend a lot of
time reviewing the records so before i
even meet the examinee i'm familiar with
the records and records generally tend
to be police reports
hospital records
medical records investigation reports
there can be any kind of relevant
records
this case was a little unusual because
the bulk of the records were actually
facebook postings largely from lauren
cataract
but
background could be anything could be
military records whatever the records
are that is appropriate to what i'm
examining somebody for
past police records passed arrest
records i could give you a list of
records so i'll ask the attorney who
retains me whether it's a defense lawyer
or prosecutor please give me what's
called the discovery all the records so
that i can become familiar with the
facts of this of this case
once i do that i schedule a meeting with
the examinee and hold the meeting it
usually is two to three hours
sometimes depending on the complexity of
the case followed up by other meetings
during the
sessions with the examinee i take notes
and uh the notes of my own notes they
look like this
they're handwritten notes
and uh these are notes which are not
they're not opinions but they're simply
my impression not my impressions but
what the person told me in response to
questions
i then uh put together the background
and the notes and write a report in this
case there was one single report dated
august 17 2020 after all four or five
exams were done
and this report consists of 19 pages and
this contains my diagnosis and all of my
findings
there are sometimes follow-up reports
especially when new material surfaces
but in this case there was no follow-up
report there is the singular report of
august 17th and this contains all my
opinions now subsequent to the report mr
um blinkist has given me other materials
and more postings but it was all more of
the same so there was nothing in the
additional materials i saw that would
cause me to write a revised report a
revised report would come that there was
something really different or if
something i said look not to be accurate
so that's the process in that report
then i have a diagnosis and i tried to
address the questions the lawyer put to
me namely what was mr barry's own state
of mind at the time of this
shooting
[Music]
and that's it i sometimes get called to
testify in court about that as i am
today
no
did you review anything that would that
address
of whether or not michael barrissone was
sleeping
leading up to this event
i'm sorry that he had been sleeping
before this happened sleeping or not
sleeping although he had terrible
insomnia
well he not just what i said but there
were all kinds of witnesses on there his
girlfriend mary haskins um
ruth cox who's a family friend larry
davidson who's the man they had there
jason what's his name his assistant
trainer the young people who came
forward who were training on the farm
there must have been at least 10 or 15
people who all said the same thing that
michael barrason looked terrible in the
last few days this was not the michael
barrison they knew that he could barely
get one foot in front of the other or
get two or three words together that he
looked as if he hadn't slept several of
these people and not not even interested
people like his girlfriend but just kids
who were training on the farm would
comment that he looked terrible some of
them thought that he was going to commit
suicide
some of them say he wasn't sleeping he
looked just horrible and this was not
the man they knew they knew him as a
tall rather heroic character an olympian
someone who was a leader someone who
trained them and he had turned into in
their words really a human wreck now in
your report did you discuss
or did you
[Music]
discuss with michael barrisson
what he believed
was going to happen to him
after
dc p and p came to the
farm well yes he was convinced the
children would be taken away
the children would be harmed the
children would be taken away and this
was now on top of all the other fears
that the horses would be harmed by
by a cataract and goodwin
that tanaraki goodwin would take away
his farm take away his possessions
destroy his reputation in the equestrian
community so in addition to all these
other fears of what cataract and goodwin
were going to do to him
all these spheres which had been built
up in his paranoia there was now a brand
new fear that had never been there
before the dp and ecp and p were going
to take away
uh
mary haskin gray's children and that was
the last straw that could have been
other last draws but that was the thing
that immediately precipitated his arming
himself to defend himself
driving down and having the
confrontation
and did he indicate to you what if
anything
he believed with regards to his personal
safety and the safety of mary haskins
they were frightened to death they he
thought that goodwin and cataract were
going to kill them
now
in formulating your opinion
did any single document or statement
um
control
no
no it was the build up of thousands and
thousands of documents over a period of
years and really coming to fruition in
the last few months before the shooting
itself did any single interview
um
control
uh what your opinion uh is here today no
it it did not and and everyone who tried
to intervene was impotent to do so
whether it was to tarshish his lawyer
his girlfriend family members no one
seemed to be able to get through to him
as he became increasingly down the let's
say the rabbit hole of this abject fear
that goodwill and counteract would
destroy him
what what are your opinions
that you formed
reviewing everything in its entirety
mr
uh barista in my opinion has two
diagnoses to a reasonable degree of
medical probability and diagnoses are
taken from what's called the dsm-5 which
is the fifth edition of the diagnostic
manual of the american psychiatric
association it's not a textbook but it's
a uniform set of criteria by which
doctors will agree on diagnoses
so the first diagnosis is delusional
disorder
delusional disorder
um
and the second diagnosis is
persistent depressive disorder
can you explain to the ladies and
gentlemen the jury what a delusional
disorder
is that we can understand all right
there are there are these are two very
different diagnoses and really in
psychiatry somebody can have two
diagnoses just like in internal medicine
you can have diabetes and asthma the
fact that you have one doesn't preclude
the other so people often have multiple
diagnoses and he has two
delusional disorder and the specific
type is persecutory type
is the unreasonable belief
to a delusional unrealistic point of
view that you're being conspired against
harmed
poisoned
and destroyed
now
the last tricks there are other kinds of
delusional disorders this delusional
disorder jealous type that's not what he
has jealous type is where you think that
your spouse is having some kind of
relationship with something that's
completely unfeasible
but this is
the most common kind of delusional
disorder is persecutory type it is in
some regards like schizophrenia
schizophrenia is a well-known diagnosis
of mental illness it's the big daddy of
mental illnesses
he does not have schizophrenia
schizophrenia someone is out of touch
with reality
they're hearing voices they're seeing
things they're hearing god talking to
them
they are shouting they're screaming
that's schizophrenia
delusional disorder has only a piece of
that
that in general his thinking is intact
in general he's not screaming he's not
seeing things but there are islands of
his thinking which are contaminated by
delusional thinking that is everything
that had to do
with lauren canara and her family and
friends
was became delusional he had unrealistic
outlandish beliefs about the things that
she would do or could do to him and no
one was able to reason him out of it
that's what a delusional disorder is a
simple delusion is a false belief any of
us can have a false belief that we have
an enemy that wants to harm us but
usually when you talk to friends and
family and you look at evidence you get
talked out of the false belief and you
realize maybe the guy doesn't like you
but he's not going to kill you
when you have a delusional disorder you
don't get talked out of the false belief
the core
false belief is that lauren kanarak was
going to annihilate him he genuinely in
his bones believed that and did
everything he could to try to protect
himself against this delusion so that's
diagnosis number one
diagnosis number two is persistent
depressive disorder this is really a
chronic depression despite his
accomplishments his bravado
the fact that he looked like a million
bucks when he was in the olympics or did
dressage is basically a depressed person
and this probably has to do with the
abuse he sustained as a child on the
part of his father that we know about
from his therapist
the fact that he had two marriages that
he couldn't sustain the fact that all of
his life was professionally satisfying
there were parts of it which were marked
by sadness and depression now these two
things are not related he has a
delusional disorder which is a fairly
uncommon condition
and he has a persistent depressive
disorder which is a very common
condition
for these two diagnosis
breakdown
do they meet your criteria
sure well it's quarter after why don't
we take our uh morning break and i'll
discuss you outside uh outside the
presence of the jurors so they can relax
for a little while
break ladies and gentlemen
you